joining us here on the show good friend
of the program who also I believe and I
think we're about to confirm this fact a
Rich Eisen show exclusive he was the one
who loaned the quarter of a million
dollars to Sean Payton to help motivate
the team he's Cameron Jordan how are you
cam I'm good no you think that was not
you is what you're saying
huh I don't even know the situation that
you're talking about you know whatever
happens the same bill aids of the things
building so all account okay because we
saw a photograph of a bunch of bricks of
alleged alleged photograph of a bunch of
alleged bricks of alleged $1 bills
surrounded from what looks like a 2009
Lombardi Trophy so that did not happen
in the Saints locker room is what you're
saying I know I haven't had the pleasure
of earning a Lombardy trophy yet but I
feel that we are on our path to do so so
I couldn't even tell you what it looked
like it's not mine okay it's not yours I
Pro you know what I respect this Cameron
Jordan I respect this sort of stuff out
of you I understand that you're focused
on the task at hand what was it like on
that sideline down 14 nothing on Sunday
the best I could put it was late I mean
honestly
all that guys are focused on the task at
hand we talked about the first quarter
we had we knew we were gonna you know
take their best punch and give it bigger
is their best shot all they had you know
that first quarter just like they did
the first time we played um and they did
just that so honestly we came together
as a group and said you know we
tightened up and looked each other in
the eye said hey all we need is one and
then of course you know Marshawn makes a
huge turnover you know all the energy
went back to us even though we were down
14 you know that was a it was almost
like nothing we could we could do we
were dialed in now are you one of those
guys that's on the sidelines saying that
this game is still for yours to be had
despite being down to scores is that
your do you find that being your role
Cameron Jordan I mean it is not even
anything that needed to be said but
everybody had their piece in it
you know everybody was inspired and we
can create one turnover everybody was
inspired to create one play because we
we already knew that it's not it's not
something that's been new to us it has
to be down you know two touchdowns in
the first quarter or whatever it was in
the first half it doesn't really matter
what we are we know that we have 45
minutes left to play you know we've got
a half a half left to play we had a
quarter left to play and once we got
ahold of the lead we never looked back
so a lot of folks are ascribing the
turnaround and momentum also to the fake
punt that worked were you aware that
that was on that that play was on on the
sidelines no I was I was with everybody
else but you know I saw that sean has
been gutsy this whole year I feel that
you know he's got a confidence in our
special teams unit he's got confidence
in her defense just in cases you know it
didn't succeed and you know with our
specialties you know making the play
that they have this year you have all
the confidence in the world that we do
the right thing yeah I know and Phillies
defense was on the field so they mean
talk about gutsy it's not as if it was
the special teams unit they were kind of
expecting it ran it anyway and so you
weren't ready to come back on the field
you were where were you were you
watching it were you in a huddle you
were an attack I don't know I think
we're still at a deal on I think we're
still decide getting ready for that next
defensive series so whatever that might
take it over Cameron Jordan here on the
Rich Eisen show and then when Lattimore
picked it off at the end walk me through
the sequence after that Cameron yeah
Marshawn picks it off you know we're in
mid pass rush it's not the way our deal
I pass versus the entire game made tolls
uncomfortable at the pocket you know he
was throw you made some errant throws
and you know we turn around after ball
was released Marshawn picks it off go
for a steel block on the intended
receiver and you know that was sort of
that what once you realize we sort of
secured and secured that you secured the
win
I saw that you know a LeSean was still
down the grass up you know my gay bro
let me help you up today yo there all
right
you never you never turned around or
whatever to to receive help but that
being said you know I could only imagine
what he was he was feeling and that
after we secured the wind I could I
could become a human again I can feel
compassion I could feel everybody good
you know honestly I just hope that he
he's definitely you know have a better
season this year yeah I mean that was uh
that was an unbelievable turn of events
and I gotta be honest with you it did
look like the Eagles were gonna get that
Nick Nick Foles magic again was that
something throughout the week you were
talking about wanting to extinguish Tam
for sure I mean he has every right to
say he has been special in the playoffs
he has every a capability shown that he
could be specially at the playoffs and
that's something that you know we have
to be aware we had to try and contain
especially when you talk about the
position he was trying to put in his
team in we could have gone in to wait
could could have you know got him over
time could not have I don't know what's
possibility is we have to worry about
what is of course yeah was 22 14 at the
time and who knows what would happen and
I look I know the obviously the times
are different postseason regular season
I understand the final scores are not
even indicative of this was the same two
teams just a few weeks apart I am gonna
ask you the question though preparing
for and playing against the Eagles is it
more difficult to face foals than once
Tamra Jordan went to Cal here on the
Rich Eisen show okay now the Rams are
coming into the house have you heard
Cameron Jordan Marcus Peters sending a
love message to your coach have you
heard this I've been made aware of it a
couple of times last night after the
game I refused to listen to it I mean at
the end a banter is one thing but you
understand that Marcus Peters is can't
be a special player so he's been known
to back back is talked up he's been
known to be a spark
you know I'm not gonna draw attention
away from our focus and in terms of that
I mean does Sean Payton talk to the
defenders while while they're out on the
field does he talk to the opponents like
that camp yeah I have no idea
usually when I'm on the sidelines we're
focusing for the next defensive series
we do know that you know emotions run
high everywhere you know all coaches all
coaches desk all teammates all players
feel the emotions the highs and lows of
games so I could care less what's
happening as long as it doesn't affect
our team okay so now this the I assume
you watch did you watch the Saturn and
game between the Rams and the Cowboys
you catch I have not you have not seen
your bow tonight I watched absolutely no
football if it didn't pertain to the
Eagles you know I watch the Chicago
Bears game i watch the last couple of
games you know focused on our task at
hand all right so now will I watch all
that is around coming up for sure today
I will have in this reel reel of not
only you know the last time we played
the rounds but the last couple games
they play what is the challenge then
what do you think is your challenge and
the defensive line unit that obviously
Sheldon Rankin's were expecting will not
be part of now cam um you know we still
have to focus I feel that Taylor
stallworth played extremely well last
night David on D'Amato played extremely
well that was a huge blow to lose
Sheldon wrinkles I mean that's like you
know a little brother so I mean talk
about what he's meant to be and what
he's meant to Lionel would be to the
defense that's the impact that you can't
get back you know but we will have to
use that next man up mentality and I
think we are capable of creating
pressure with guys like David atomic
Davis Center Taylor so then after we're
again 273 rushing yards the Rams racked
up with CJ Anderson now looking you know
unlike what he used to look like
physically for the Broncos coming down
hill as well what does that present to
you Cameron
first of all go bears and second of all
right there you go problem you know we
have to tend to where the team by two
Golden Bears that's something that y'all
but no all seriousness he clearly had a
hell of a showing and even like what was
at the last two games that he was in yep
he had a hell of a showing so it's not
like we haven't placed Todd Gurley it's
not like we you know this year we have
not faced CJ but we understand that it's
gonna be up to us to make them
one-dimensional that mean at the end day
that got the golf they've got Brandon
cooks their wide receiver quarters bed
nice so we have to try and do it we can
to make them a one-dimensional team what
would it mean to you last 140 Cameron
Jordan to win the next two games and win
at all I mean seriously yeah in your
quiet moments you think about just
playing all out in your head here not
yet yeah I don't allow myself to think
big picture right now we've still got
the game ahead of us you can't put the
cart before the horse how do you think
it's going to be Sunday at home man it
was bananas this last Sunday
don't field advantage is a real thing
for us the crowd is rocking our team is
stopping and you can't really you can't
really put a pole a plug on us honestly
I love when were firing off at all
cylinders that it's it's gonna be a hell
of a game yeah it is it is it is one of
the loudest joints I mean the both
championship games are in some of the
loudest joints indoors and outdoors in
the history of the NFL Cameron Jordan
appreciate the call after the day after
the big win let's chat again soon no
doubt you got it see now you are talking
about it you are talking about it hey
you know just I said hopefully well no
yeah you came on before the Super Bowl
last year in Minnesota you know where
your dad played for many many many many
years maybe you can no come on after
this time you know what I'm saying
hopefully okay cam you take care of
yourself all right
okay that's Cameron Jordan Saints
defensive lineman here on the Rich Eisen
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience